let's do a hard segue and we'll talk
about what's going on with the truckers
we got the story from global news
crossing delayed monday at manitoba u.s
border as truckers protest vaccine
mandate have you guys seen this a bunch
of truckers blocked both directions the
canadian u.s border so that it was it
was it was difficult to enter and
difficult to leave because canada is
going to be imposing a vaccine mandate
where if you are a u.s citizen a trucker
you can't enter canada unless you're
vaccinated and if you're a canadian
trucker and you enter and you're not
vaccinated you have to quarantine so
naturally people are protesting
and uh
at a time when there's already shortages
at a time when the policies in this
regard have already failed
it seems like i'm sorry man i know
people don't like hearing it but
it's almost intentional gutting of the
system because you know truckers aren't
going to go for this and you know
without them you won't get food so why
do it it's like they're trying to
destroy the economy on purpose it's like
they're trying to have something like a
great reset it's like they're trying to
destroy the current system that we're
living under in order to rebound rebuild
back a new one that works in their favor
and i i think chaos is the name of the
game i think that's what they're trying
to achieve there's always this kind of
prevailing idea of order out of chaos
and if you look at a lot of the moves
that governments have been making
throughout human history those are the
moves that they're making they create
chaos they thrive off that situation
they create the problem they have a
reaction that they know is going to be
created by it and of course then they
bring in the solution which works in
their favor because there's no
explanation this is not based on any why
are they doing this there's no science
there's no data there's no information
saying that this is going to help anyone
except destroy the economy we got the
story from tim cast federal government
moves forward program that permits teens
to become truck drivers
the trucking industry is in need of of
an estimated 80 000 drivers so what's
the plan teenagers are more likely to
get the vac so the truckers who quit
over the vaccine mandate will be
replaced by teenagers is that is that
what's happening
i i gotta say man look i feel like a
chicken in a chicken coop i got no idea
what their plan is it doesn't make sense
people are taking dumps in their water
and then claiming they're not and i'm
just like
you know let me let me just just say
people underestimate how clown clowned
out the clown world is there's a video i
tweeted about about you know some some
person saying
some of their pronouns are clown and
clown self and i'm like yeah that about
explains it yeah that's right you know
what think about the the bombing of uh
london you brought this up last week uh
during the blitzkrieg
mike rowe brought it up yeah mike
brought this up and that after a few
days of bombing they just climbed out of
the basement and got back to life and as
normal because you have no other choice
it was a real emergency you had to take
back control of your life this isn't
okay i don't want to step out i don't
want to say something that i regret
later but it's this is not the bombing
of of london what we're going through
right now people are not getting their
bodies exploded and running for their
life
so
is this some is this a real emergency
rat utopia i'm sorry you compare it to
war it's not not like that right the rat
hope experiment they put us under
lockdown everyone panics begins to go
nuts then they take us out dry us off
put them back put us back in and then we
swim for 60 hours yeah if this was a
real emergency we wouldn't be waiting
for authority to give us the go ahead
well to play devil's advocate and i'm
not saying that this is what i believe
i'm just saying like is there any other
reason why they would be doing this i
absolutely believe there are people in
power who
are doing this for control for authority
but i'm wondering like what about aren't
there people in positions of power who
genuinely believe it themselves and are
just as caught as people watching msnbc
and like genuinely believe that this is
going to work like through their
arrogance and their certainty about
their version of reality they think that
if they do this they are going to get
people to get vaccinated i'm not saying
it's right but is it possible that it's
not always sinister it's not always
nefarious and manipulative it's actually
just people who are also programmed well
then we got a problem because there's a
zombie horde taking over and they're
marching through the streets they're
unable to tell you know what it is
i i explained this of jack dorsey
he creates twitter twitter creates
fertile uh ground for the refuse of the
far left broken ideologies
jack dorsey having created twitter and
now following people who are trapped in
the sewer of twitter he begins drinking
his own refuse and believing his own
insanity and then his opinions get
shaped thinking this is reality when in
reality he made a big toilet a big
toilet for people to take dumps into
with their garbage ideas he absorbs
those garbage ideas thinks they're real
so what we have is there's there's a
possibility that there is a cabal of
powerful individuals who are pulling the
strings with big corporate donations
with lobbying and things like that i
think that's true obviously to a certain
extent but it's entirely possible that
crackpot idiots on cnn follow other
crackpot idiots and they recycle
information playing and get a big game
of telephone and then here's what
happens somebody writes an article and
they're like i need clicks so they're
like i think trump is a fascist so trump
is trump be behaving like a fascist
print
then their friend following them sees it
and they go did you read that article
talking about trump acting like a
fascist you know it's pretty fascistic
so then this guy then writes an article
saying trump is a fascist then his
friend sees it and says whoa trump is
like the fascists he's like mussolini
then he writes trump is like mussolini
then someone sees and says no not like
mussolini he's like hitler then they're
right trump is like hitler then someone
else says like trump trump is as bad as
hitler and then someone goes he's worse
they're all just basically swimming in a
circle of their own sewage exciting
themselves and then after a a week of
telephone they're all screaming that
trump is the reemergence of hitler and
it's like yo you guys are nuts calm down
stop drinking each other's waste and
just actually get out there and talk to
real people they don't do it so now
they're screaming bill maher brings it
up that democrats were polled and they
were asked what the likelihood was
percentage-wise of needing
hospitalization if you get covered and
they said 50 percent and he was like
what
republicans and independent voters got
it right 5
but these are people who believe each
other hyping each other up constantly
one-upping garbage fake news until
they're like lock the whole country down
burn to the ground otherwise everyone
dies they are running around screaming
the sky is falling and for some reason
we've been listening to them and arguing
with them instead of just excising them
from political discourse and saying do
whatever you want i'll be over here
living i disagree with both of you guys
surprise surprise i believe it's a
conspiracy because for for this kind of
ignorance to to be perpetrated right i'm
not saying it's not i might be wrong but
but for this type of policy to be
implemented because of popular support
people have to say to themselves the
vaccine mandates worked so great that we
have to implement more vaccine mandates
and i think it's pretty clear to the
average person paying attention that
they absolutely did it i mean there's
even trudeau and fauci coming out on
record saying that these mandates these
vaccine mandates aren't about health
they're about convincing other people to
take the shot so this kind of fervent
policy making that clearly is disrupting
the economy clearly is going to have
negative effects when already the store
shelves are barren in some places when
already the supply chain has been
disrupted asking for more supply chain
disruptions is literally creating chaos
so i'm sticking to what i personally
believe and that's my personal feeling
and i could be wrong because i don't
think it's idiots leading the herd i
think it's uh you know a few
powerful people creating the the idiots
that are bringing them along but there's
not a lot of them uh still when it comes
to the bigger official story of kovid
which is breaking let's make a short
film
a zombie apocalypse happens and it's
like it starts off very much like a
zombie movie it's like run you know get
the shotgun oh jesus zombies are coming
and then we'll have ian be like you know
i was listening to what they were saying
uh
i kind of agree i'm gonna go join them
and we're like no ian you want to go
talk to him i'll be back oh you think i
should just full-on just go join them
like it kind of makes sense i'll come in
the middle of the night i'll wake you up
tim i've been listening to the zombies
they've been telling me
i don't have to make any tough decisions
no no you got to be like he's here
they've been saying brains so much i
kind of wonder if eating brains does
make sense
i think we should consider like ian
you're turning into one of them and they
don't actually bite you to make you a
zombie you just listen to them enough
and then you start believing brains and
then listen to it on repeat on youtube
too all the zombies they actually aren't
infected with anything they're just all
scared to step out of line because the
other zombies will attack them if they
act like they're not zombies so it's
actually a horde of people pretending to
be zombies that's mass formation
psychosis that is that would be actually
a funny little skit to do
where it's just like a bunch of people
who are like i'm a zombie and no one
dare step out of line and then one guy
goes
wait a minute you guys aren't actually
zombies and they're like brains and they
attack them and they're all looking
around like oh i'm a zombie
oh i got a question for you guys justin
trudeau is he evil mastermind or is he
fool that's being provoked by the evil
mastermind he seems like a mastermind to
me i don't know how blatantly he's just
willing to say like yeah we're gonna
violate your rights we don't and maybe
he's just so far gone that he thinks
that's acceptable because i know there
are a lot of people who feel that way
but he was dealing arms to the saudis
for years and it's been well documented
how their human rights track record and
what they do in yemen and he had no
problem arming them yeah he's true and
true and authoritarian he's he's a
communist he loves centralization he was
literally cheerleading china because of
the way that they run their economy you
know
china literally destroys human rights
for their economy and this is something
that trudeau openly praises and looks up
to so i wouldn't even say mastermind or
puppet i would say sociopath that's been
put in a position of power that's
playing out the agenda of the world
economic forum of the davos group and is
reading the handbook and following every
single procedure that they ask him to
follow i don't know his dad but his dad
was the prime minister before him fidel
castro
was his dad notoriously authoritarian or
people people keep posting photos of him
next to fidelity
he looks like fidel castro
i'm not going to hold it again i do look
like putin
if if putin bill maher and julian
assange had a love child i would pop out
but that's a different story but uh i
don't think i'm related to putin who
knows uh but my i do look like you are
but
this would explain why he's an
authoritarian communist because you know
fidel is an authoritarian communist
there's like a a a long-lost
autobiography from putin where he talks
about how he once ventured to poland in
the mid to mid 80s
and had an affair with luke and he's
like i am your father yeah
well i was a part of the resistance
against the soviet union so when putin
was a kgb agent my family was going up
against the communists a part of the
salidernos movement in northern poland
and dainzing so what if there's like a
whirlwind affair where vladimir is like
i kind of be with you it is forbidden so
there could be a star wars movie here
with me
being unopposed in sides and then my
family helping take down the soviet
union which of course is the evil empire
which putin was a kgb agent of that is
possible i think the better story is
that putin had a series of clones made
when he was in the kgb and like they
were supposed to be destroyed yeah and
and and luke is programmed to be
activated as a sleeper agent for the
soviet union
we'll make a clone with different
mindsets yeah one is very very anarchist
this is very important news we're
discussing right now yeah that's very
important
there are a lot of people who i see
comments when they're saying you know
it's too pessimistic to talk about
things falling apart
and i'm like what should we talk about
no i i mean that sincerely like uh i
think watching the media collapse is not
bad news i think it's a good thing i
find that watching cnn um trying to
think your way out of the psychosis
doesn't work it's like no thought is the
way to to get away from that stuff which
is why i usually turn off the tv if it
looks step outside or something if you
turn the tv off
and go outside and ignore the mainstream
media and just say like tend to your
goats or chickens for a week when you
turn the tv on it'll be like it'll be
like watching saturn it'll be a
different planet you'll be like what
what are they talking about because the
news changes so rapidly these days like
like you if you listen to dr fauci this
i mentioned this you know
a while back he'll come out and he'll be
like you don't need to be wearing two
masks but then three days later he's
like you should be wearing two masks and
then you get one person who watched one
story
and then didn't see the update and the
other person who sees the update and now
they're arguing online about who's right
and who's wrong and it's like yo
i bet you could spend seven days away
and miss this news cycle changing three
times and come back and not even know it
changed yeah and have nothing to argue
about well i i think no no i think it'll
be like you know fauci will come out i
mean joe biden comes out joe biden said
that the vaccines would stop the spread
of the pandemic yeah that's not what
they're saying now so if you were
someone who passively watched the news
and heard biden say that you'd be like
oh how about that today you turn the
news on and they're saying something
totally different you'd be like what did
i like go into the twilight zone or
something do these people forget do they
have amnesia that's the funniest thing
when there are there are people
on twitter tweeting at me being like uh
duh the the vaccines do x and i'm like
that's not what joe biden or fauci or or
the cdc director said three months ago i
understand science changes
but isn't it a bit too rapid because if
it is changing this rapidly then there's
no plan and it's very likely to change
again yeah you have to be in sorry no go
ahead okay i'll just go really quickly
you have to be traumatized to be believe
the official story and there's a lot of
people who are traumatized that the
corporate media and the politicians
scare the crap out of every single day
and that's the only way that they could
get them in a state that's irrational
not paying attention and has them going
along with the big overlord state saying
we will protect you when of course
they're doing the complete opposite of
that sorry go ahead no i was just gonna
say it's like okay yes science does
change but it would go a very long way
if the people who are constantly
changing the opinions could just
acknowledge oh okay well it changed it's
wrong and you don't see that you see
people getting gaslit and people being
blamed as and being shamed for
questioning things when it's always
changing like how can you not have a
healthy level of skepticism you're
allowed to to notice that there are
discrepancies and sure okay science may
explain that but if you could just drop
the arrogance and the hubris about it i
think they would have a lot better
chance of communicating with people they
think need to hear it what wasn't our
good friend wasn't it our good friend
ethan klein who said you don't even need
to think right
didn't he say yeah yeah that's why you
said you just go to the web the
government's website you don't even need
to think do what the government tells
you
i mean i kind of read history books when
i was growing up
you don't do that in fact
we were always told that dissent was
patriotic in this country now you have
this massive group of people who are
like
dissent is can is cons is insurrection
is wrong don't do it just do what you're
told this is the funny thing about the
vaccine mandates when they say the
vaccine mandates work but new york is
experiencing a major surge in covet
cases what they're really saying is the
vaccines force people to get uh
vaccinated the mandates do yeah i'm
sorry sorry the mandates
work
and what they mean is it's forcing
people to get it
i thought they meant initially and i
probably shouldn't assume this that it
was going to actually stem the spread
because joe biden said that right now
that's not the case it's to reduce the
severity and i'm like well the hospitals
are overloaded fact and there's
record-breaking amounts of covet also a
fact tons of people are getting i mean
glenn beck had it recently mike rowe
mentioned he had it over christmas i
think crowder had it i could be wrong
yeah he did everybody's getting it
so
now they're saying well it was never
supposed to stop the spread was supposed
to reduce the severity of symptoms and
i'm like you said joe biden actually
said that it would you know it would all
be over they actually said several times
once everyone gets vaccinated you don't
gotta wear masks and the pandemic will
end and it's not ending now i think it's
fair to say okay maybe they got it wrong
but at a certain point they should be
like it's probably gonna change
we don't know for sure but everyone's so
sure of themselves yeah they didn't know
that had waning immunity so how did they
know anything else surrounding this very
specifically yeah yeah
exactly the same thing pretty much uh
but but the official story has changed
so many times that these bureaucrats
have flip-flopped so many times it's
difficult to even understand where we're
at right now and i think the strategy
that they're implementing right now is
let's just spin people around so they
get confused that don't know what's
going on and it's all going to be scary
unless you just obey us that's that's
the policy that they have implemented
because
you know it's only going to be a certain
time now where people are going to be
like okay i'm going to stop spinning now
i'm going to start paying attention to
what's going on here because we've been
bamboozled we've been we've been lied to
and i think this larger mass awakening
is happening and it's going to have some
very severe effects on our society and
our political system this is why the
democrats are giving up kovid in my
opinion right before this upcoming
election because they can't win with
this policy that has destroyed people's
lives and only enriched the billionaire
class they can't i'm not i don't i don't
think people want to to accept that when
i say
not everybody just there are some people
who don't accept when i say that the
country is breaking apart or that states
are breaking apart i don't see that as a
bad thing i mean luke brought up
peaceful divorce a while ago michael
malus has talked about it so hawaii
recently announced that you need a
booster shot to enter the state
california wants to double their taxes
so they can pay for universal health
care
well obviously california will struggle
to make that work i mean they're going
to require heavy subsidy rich people are
going to walk out of the state then
they're going to try and tax them 10
years after the fact that's one thing
they announced and then you're going to
see a bunch of poor people flood into
the state to get free health care
clearly doesn't work but hey
let people go to the state they want
with the laws they want people will
leave if there ends up being some kind
of fracturing of this country it means
yo i'm gonna go to west virginia
i'm gonna have all my guns i'll be very
pleased and happy and then the people
who don't like guns a month and band can
go to california and then they can have
free health care what's the problem how
is that a bad thing what about artillery
all of it artillery can fire across
state lines
what if it's banned in one state but
it's legal in the other state yeah
that's too bad for the state that banned
it i guess
that sounds like an arms race
whatever yeah
yeah
thomas massey tweeted
what piece of second amendment
legislation should we should we push if
we take control and and everyone was
like abolish the atf repeal the nfa and
i'm like yes those things i i went
further and i said man gun mandates if
you want to go out to a diner you got to
have proof of gun and you've got to be
able to show that it's loaded and proof
of gun
so you'll walk up to the diner and
they'll be like we have a gun mandate in
this city if you want to come in you
have to be armed and you're like oh i've
got my 1911 right here i got my proof on
my right i've got a revolver let me show
you my 38 or whatever and uh you can
walk it maybe with a right you got to
have a gun gun mandates mandatory gun
ownership thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at
8pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time